you know what I've been noticing
that Geo seems to be the one having all
the fun trying on all these clothes
having all these hauls all the time but
guess what
every five years I have my own two and
don't you dare make fun of me it's
because I save all of my money so that
my wife can have a great life
so for me you know I don't got that
money I'm just kidding now for me I
think I go so much for comfort that I
stick to the same joggers tees shorts
all the time yes I rock barbell all the
time
and um
I think I just want things to be like
easy but me and Jill been talking and I
want to look presentable for her you
know so I was like like because I was
like one of those things where she was
like you know what I I missed the days
where like you know we used to go out on
dates and stuff and like we look good
for each other I was like you know what
you right boo you know what I mean so um
I don't want to go against my natural
inclination which is to be comfy so I
like to have what I call my daily
drivers the problem is when you buy
actual daily drivers for your daily
drivers you look busted like your shoes
get beat up your your clothes look
frumpy like it doesn't look good so this
time I went into my uh shopping spree
with the mindset of what could be a
daily driver like it's not something got
a dry clean or I have to iron a certain
way or else it's not gonna look good
like it's the maintenance is very easy
and I can put it on like it's a daily
driver but it doesn't look like one so I
can wear it daily so for example one of
the things I already got I got these
from Ariana hi these are technically
like four-way stretch
camping pants
but since it's 100 polyester I could
just pop these on as if I'm wearing
sweats feels like sweats but it does not
look like sweats and that's the whole
point of that so
I did a little Carhartt splurge and I'm
saying got to go with one of the OG
brands that I've been a fan of since
probably I was in high school
let's see what we got you ready for me
to impress you babe yeah first things
first
I got a jacket oh
look at that
so I got a quilted jacket let me know
when I can look at it okay on your body
so I got a quilted jacket so you can see
this is something I could just put like
on a hanger on um on the coat hanger and
that way anytime I need to leave the
house I can just grab it pull it off and
it's not some crazy like material
that I can use this as a daily driver
but it gives it a nice little touch to
whatever I'm wearing you know what I'm
saying oh
yeah I don't know how to look this good
oh damn oh man that looks good you said
you didn't look good I don't know okay
take a look what you think see
that looks really good let me see got my
little daily Drive ring on me oh she
went with the whip huh yeah just pop it
on real quick you know what I'm saying
that looks really good show up at my
kids sports and all the other moms are
like damn what's your name my name is
Barbara what's your name shut the
up I'm kidding I'm just kidding taking a
nap
so I've got this jacket quick little
daily driver action not too fancy one of
the mistakes I made before is I'll find
something I really like like I have this
Nike
um like letterman jacket if you guys
might have seen in the old JK videos the
sleeves are red and the main part is
like a felt gray It's So Dope but it's
also so loud that you wear it once and
you wear it the second time someone's
like hey I saw you wear that already and
so it attracts so much attention so it's
not a daily driver it feels comfortable
with that like a daily driver but you
can't wear it that many times it needs
to be a wow piece so I got way more
muted colors this time where you can
wear it every day
it ain't nobody gonna say nothing
next up I got some cargo pants I am so
happy that cargo pants are back in
because they're just so freaking well it
depends how you wear them feet
they're so comfy so Carhartt once again
big so nosy I should be working right
now you literally told me you don't have
time I did I know but I'm just so good
but guess what
check it out you know what I'm saying I
got cargo
pants it's the rip stock material
oh got a baggier fitment too so that you
know I mean how can they look tight is
it because you're fat right now because
I got a fat ass I got a donker you know
what I'm saying so got that oh damn
already looks good with this barbell tea
plants need to see that gotta get got
some dope shoes coming in too
bam stupid look how steezy I look
at that
this is my this is gonna be my what I'm
wearing regular on the regular I go to
supermarket Honeys be all up on my jock
already like damn that guy got some ribs
you know what I'm saying the kids say
rizz these days too by the way
don't say it then true
it looks good what are we gonna do about
the face did you get anything to cover
the face that's impossible the ladies
could be like God damn that mysterious
man is fun as no his head is a
little big though okay check it out got
another one another one did this come
with a hard drive another what jacket
you love jackets
because it's so damn hot
yeah what you're thinking oh I love this
jacket so
I had a jacket like this I believe these
are called a canvas or denim jackets
and I bought one from my off brand not
off brand not as in fake but like you
know how like you can tell certain items
came from a certain company and other
companies will make it too but they're
not The Originators of it so like
for example a good one would be like
down jackets everyone knows you want to
get a down jacket and it better be
Canada Goose or better be North Face or
something like that yes Adidas will make
a down jacket but when you rock Adidas
down jacket you look stupid because
that's everyone knows that's not the
brand that made the thing right so I had
a canvas jacket like this it was by
Brixton I think
and they're kind of like a brand that's
like all around they get carried by
Tilly's Nordstroms whatever but they're
not known for Workwear like Carhartt or
Dickies or Ben Davis's
so ever since I got that I knew that
um I couldn't pass the poser test
because people like what what is that is
that a Brixton that I'm John you better
get yourself a real one I'm like you
know what you're right so I got myself a
real one this time and got myself a
little Carhartt denim jacket
and this is the real real you know what
I mean
look at that pow oh oh I got it with the
lining on the inside see that look at
that baby
oh that looks good exactly Jesus Christ
I hate you look at that
and every time I get new clothes
all of my nephews get hooked up
because Geo has a nephew that's pretty
big now he's like about to be 14.
and he gets to have all my old clothes
got that got oh
man I keep getting more and more I got
more stuff than I thought I did so
here's another daily driver
oh this is gray
this turned out better than I thought so
I actually thought this fleece jacket
was gonna be black and I was like oh too
many black beans but I'm like you know
what it's daily drivers I want to keep
it muted and I'm glad that it's actually
gray so it gives some of the clothes
that I got some variation but it's still
a muted color
so that uh
it doesn't stand out but I do actually
have some variation and don't tell me
this the zipper got caught the first day
please please don't
please don't tell me it got caught on
the first day please oh my god did he
get caught no please don't tell me I got
cuddled oh there we go
all right
oh damn it's soft
like this
bam see daily driving I'm saying pop it
on
wow wow look at this baby
that one looks sick you have a great eye
that's why I'm the creative director I
borrow Brigade you know what I'm talking
about they'll just pay me the big bucks
because I own the company
actually they don't pay me the big bucks
no there's people in the coming that get
paid more than me but anyways
that's not the main point okay I got
another box not sure if this is also
part of the package
oh
man is this from Kiss I did buy
something I bought some shoes
[Music]
you're scaring me up yeah come on oh I'm
sorry Mia Mia
but got some you know what I'm saying
some Pumas what you know about the Pumas
Pumas exactly I would never buy Puma
Pumas that's your problem you know I'm
saying that's your problem not mine
damn look at that boom
I hate how good you look yeah Bobby
Huntress put me in the lookbook
look at that
put me in a put me on a lookbook come
call me a model you know what I'm saying
I got that
you gotta work on your poses a little
bit yeah
does that not look good or what that's
really good yeah
did you get anything for the face though
I keep asking
I'm getting a haircut tomorrow okay
what about that
one pet two jackets about it what else
bam you know what the actual challenge
is
the challenge is I have a good eye
the challenge is if I keep up with it
because my wardrobe is actually full of
dope that I just never wanted but
hopefully this time I keep up with it
because I got stuff that's not hard to
maintain
um like all white shoes or something
those are really hard to maintain
but tatao another pair you know what I'm
saying
hey
you know what I mean
damn player player
damn those shoes come tighter
there you go loosen it up
loosen it up
I used to be a Die Hard like Air Max guy
got 90s 95s 97s ones
but I was like you know I should
probably expand my palette so
saw these it's a time not they're pretty
sick look at these
boom
town
got that look at that dude I'm ready
look at this
put me in a
fashion shoot yeah you look good put me
in a fashion shoe put me in a fashion
shoot
that's what I've been translating still
pretty old and shitty but this new guy
look is hot I talked Thomas this is
busting I wish I wish you would keep up
with it though I think once every five
years you get inspired to impress me and
then you stop I keep telling people look
man I told you I got the eye I got the
eye of the tiger
but it's Gotta make sure I keep wearing
it but
I even wear it
though probably not I'm not good I'm
gonna try it I'm gonna really try
no but these shoes a little bit more
colorful a bit catchier right so these
aren't my daily drivers these are
probably somewhere on the weekend I even
bought some daily driver shoes some like
all black shoes all gray shoes that I
think would
uh look good
um that I can work consistently but bam
a little bit of milk look I'm ready to
battle someone
if you guys like that town hall
let me know in the comments below I'll
do more of them because I was actually
pretty fun putting on a bunch of clothes
um and that gives me an excuse to buy
more clothes and share some of the other
stuff that I like so let me know if I'll
do more if so maybe mine are better than
GEOS anyways you know what I'm saying
no no no